Hi I'm Dan and I work on
Open Social
and today I'm going to take
you through the basic steps
in running your own open
social applications.
So the first thing we are going
to do
is a little primer on gadgets.
And Gadgets at their basic
level are just XML files.
and so we are going to take
a quick look at what a gadget
xml file looks like
as you can see a gadget is just
xml
at the top of the file you
can see the file
you can see the xml version
type and encoding
and below that you can see
the tags that specify this
as a gadget file
we open everything up with a
module tag
and inside of that
we have module preferences.
that specify things
like the applications title
and requires features
necessary for the application
here requiring the open
social feature
and below that we actually
define the content of the gadget
here the content  type is html
inside of that we have a
"cdata" section
which is where all of our code,
our html, and java script go
and the string "hello world".
so now that that little intro's out
of the way we can
go down and run our first
social application.
so there's a couple of things
that you will need for this
First a text editor and a web
hosting account.
and in addition to that an orkut
account
and access to the
orkut sandbox
which is where we allow you to
test your social applications.
i will assume that most of you
have a text editor
and a lot of you probably
already  have web hosting
but if you don't there are two
things you can try.
First is google code project
hosting which is
a place to host open
source applications
so if you'd like to make your
gadget open source
you can host it there
and if you don't want to do that
you can use google page creator
which allows you to upload html
files and edit html files
and upload other non html files
like gadget specifications
like what we're writing here.
so once you have that out of the
way
your going to need to
to create an orkut account
which is pretty straight forward.
just goto orkut.com and it will
walk you through the steps.
once you've done that,
you're going to need to sign up
for access to the orkut sandbox.
which is pretty straight forward
as well.
we have a link that you can use
to do that.
and once you have access
you can log into
"sandbox.orkut.com"
and add your gadget
and I'll show you how to do
that right now
so what you should do is take
the text of the sample gadget
copy that into a text file
and save it on your web hosting
account as "helloworld.xml"
log in to your orkut account
click on the edit button,
next to apps on the left
hand side of the page
type in the url of your
newly created xml file
click on the add application
button
grant the application permission to
access your account
and then click on the link that it adds
to the applications on your page.
so now you have installed
your first social application into orkut.
for more information on what i just did
as well as more information on the
rest of the social API
check out the tutorial on
"code.google.com"
under the open social section.